okay so where are you at in this one for
those stars
yeah and as expected trinity berg had a
great start
gemologist okay so let's stop uh when we
get to that queen horses and bodhi
meister is done
okay right here so what's kind of going
on right here like
horses are coming out some of them i
guess
like are some of the like some of the
writers are in the lead here like
yeah is that because the the the the
jockey has like
kind of commanded them to be in the lead
or did the horse just come out strong
no a lot of horses are like being
command to go to the lead you know and
everybody is trying to be
um it's like not necessarily that you
want to go to the lead but you
want to get a clear path so you can be
like maybe like to be in front of
a horse whatever horse is behind you
because that way
you can get your position faster you
know
okay and now if a horse comes say you
you come out of the gate
and another horse kind of gets in front
of you a little bit is that bad for your
horse
yeah because then you had to you had to
regroup you have to you have to check
your horse now you have to weigh
whatever that
that horse in front of you is going to
do and then you're hoping that after
that then you get to do
you know your your strategy or basically
choose
plan b or plan z you know now you're
there now just what you do you know you
chose to stay there
or you chose to go around that horse in
front of you it's just a lot of like you
have to adjust
in the moment is there a moment there's
a horse here that's in the back and he's
only in the back by about three lengths
it looks like
and uh is that right you think how many
links has he been in the back
yeah he's probably like around six seven
likes people okay so
my length math is what he used to be i
was just trying to sound like i knew
what i was saying but
so he's about six or seven links back he
does that horse he still has a chance to
win though huh of course yeah no of
course he has
unless that horse uh uh um
um strategy or or or or um
was to go into the front the front if if
that wasn't if that was the case then
he's totally screwed
he's like not liking his chances and the
jock is realizing at that point
this is probably just not going to be
it's not going to be good yeah okay
okay cool let's let's keep it cruising
then start gemologist is also out and
where are you at right here
on the outside oh there you are cruising
huh yeah and now
bodie meister's ahead of trinity you're
kind of in the middle right now right
yeah i'm in the middle i'm gonna bounce
a little bit yeah
so you have turns here like how much
turns do you have two
two turns so you have this one and then
yeah oh
now what do you do during the turns man
well you tried to save as much turn
yeah yeah because you can't do much like
even if you're playing a racing game or
something like on the turn you're like
slow down a little bit yeah you just
have to like be in the turn there's not
you can't i feel like it's hard to use
strategy
yeah no you have to you just have to
help the horse to take the turn the best
way possible you know and then like
set up your uh uh um coming
out of the out of this first round
because you're gonna get a stretch again
you know okay
and then line up to get the second the
last turn you know
okay okay let's keep it cruising here
will take charge indy as they move into
the turn and then it's daddy knows best
on the far outside liaison creative
cause optimizer along the rail
now do you feel like you had a chance in
this race right here what were you
feeling like
i did that i have a chance because this
is a horse that i like i was i was
i got very familiar with him before
going to the kentucky derby and you have
to understand like this never happened
to me
they now happens to nobody all of a
sudden like a a kid coming from a
sea racetrack or the racetrack you know
like uh and all of a sudden
he isn't the kentucky there but first of
all it was a lot of doubts it's like you
know like
well is he even have it you know is it
really that can he be good enough to
be in this that's right does he even
have his adult teeth i'm sure a lot of
people are wondering you know
yeah oh they're probably thinking oh
he's totally gonna melt down you know or
things like that all right
pressure and all these things was there
a lot of pressure no
no i i'm very lucky that i don't the
pressure i'm
very good under pressure you know and i
couldn't
i couldn't like commute in your and
fourth right here yeah i'm for it right
now
so this is the second turn six seconds
wow i thought i was going to finish
second
because if you see that horse in the in
front okay he is like super super
in front of me oh totally and then but
my course still has some guys so i'm
thinking like
oh my god you know i'm gonna finish
second and they kentucky that way i was
pumped you know i was stopping right
here
right here okay what do you do on the
horse here so you have now you
we also have i just want to show this
here this is called a what
whip crop okay whip or crop and then
we have your helmet here okay
and so that's pretty light everybody
wears kind of the same type of helmet
yeah okay
do you now at this point how much times
can you whip the horse as much as you
want
this yeah uh but a lot of rules have
changed now now we're
we're not allowed you know but i i'm
never like uh
um um known
to him accords a lot you know so if you
see here like i hit once and then you
push your horse you know you have to
give him a chance to respond you know
but um but uh back in 2012 there wasn't
like a
a restriction on how many times you can
whip a horse it was like a step dad out
there
if you weren't yeah you could have gone
like tata like you know but does the
horse does it hurt the horse much it
doesn't
what do you think well it depends i
think back in the days it used to if i
if i show you one of the
the the the um whips that they used to
use the the old timers you know that's
really that
seriously yeah yeah that's interesting
it's not as like i mean if this were
lead it would be tough oh yeah
yeah yeah okay so here we go let's go
through this man this is crazy so what
is your strategy right here like do you
have any
no that does it like as soon as you go
to the last stretch like that's just
like try to go as fast like
try to ask your horse to finish like
yelling at the horse yeah
what do you say
wow
[Applause]
i guess like you know like you say
compare that's like our super bowl you
know like so my whole life
i was 24 years old i think most of my
whole life like just flash in front of
me you know thinking that
maybe this is why i don't watch this
replay because then i get emotional a
little bit
dude i'm emotional i wasn't even in it i
mean i've done steroids but that's the
closest i've come
i used to do them in high school the
closest i've come to get in there i
think watching the race here with you i
understand why i don't watch the race a
lot
oh i'm sorry man but it's really
exciting i think also it's a way to kind
of channel with just that that it's even
a possibility for people you know
of course it's inspiring like if there's
young men out there who think about
being jockeys
young latino men out there we have a
good latino audience
um who think about being jockeys or uh
it's interesting or they might have a
kid who's like a more of a petite sized
kid and like what could i get my kid
into
yeah you know you don't think that man
that's really almost the last thing you
think about
probably like it's either hide and go
seek or being a jockey i feel like if
you're kind of more
petite size you know hope you enjoyed
that video
and you can watch another and you can
watch this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option
not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one